all right
2023 Griffin with Griffin here we go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
yo
favorite podcast
[Music]
2012.
welcome back everybody
we doing it
happy New Year everybody I know it's
late we shouldn't be saying it but
whatever it's my first episode of 2023
and we're back I want to talk about my
New Year's resolutions I want to talk
about Avatar and or NFL playoffs
couple of other things but we back we
here I love y'all let's get going
[Music]
all right
welcome back riffing with Griffin and
we're here welcome to like I say the
podcast before Griffin go to Eric
griffin.com Hey everybody please
subscribe share like do all that stuff
that helps grow the podcast for 2023
let's make it bigger and better if
you're on Twitch man I'm on Twitch daily
I play a lot of Call of Duty so check me
out at twitch at Eric Griffin gaming I
actually put a bunch of videos up on air
Griffin gaming on um what do you call it
uh YouTube also so you know you want to
support the show I am going to start
doing a weekly uh patreon little small
patreon episode from my patreon my small
patreon community I want that to grow
too so we'll do that
so we got stuff there uh so make sure
you check me out on all of these things
and if you want to see me live hey guess
what guys this week
this week guess what I'm at the
Greensboro North Carolina
Comedy Zone your boy is coming your way
January 13th through the 15th so if
you're in Greensboro come on out to the
comedy zone and see your boy do some
comedy
2023 Style
all right so there's that and let's also
take care of a little business before we
start to uh uh let's get a little word
from our sponsor I want to thank
doordash for being a sponsor of the show
our listeners get 50 off their first
order of 15 or more when you download
the doordash app and enter code Griff
Griffin not Griffin Griffin Griffin riff
and riffin also
DraftKings Draft Kings minimum age
eligibility restriction Supply and see
the show notes for details but download
the draft gang Sports app and use code
riffin new customers get can bet five
dollars on the NFL and get 200
free bets instantly only at draftking
Sportsbook with code riffin
alright so hello everybody Welcome Back
to the podcast I need you guys to remind
me to do the mid mid-roll ads because my
last episode I forgot to do that
Griffin we're here again doing what I do
uh you can watch me on other things you
know check me out on gen to gen when we
come back for season two of gent to gen
with Matthew Espinosa I'm also on the
golden hour so check out the golden hour
those are the podcasts you can go see me
be silly all the time I like to give a
little disclaimer for those of you that
watch the podcast all the time I
appreciate you I appreciate your support
and thanks for being here always if
you're here for the first time and
you're like hey I saw you on this this
and that and you're wondering if I'm
going to be silly and crazy and funny
all the time on this this isn't a
podcast for that you know sometimes you
get that sometimes you don't it's a
stream of Consciousness I like being
sometimes I like being very serious
sometimes I like to discuss serious
topics or sometimes I like to just
discuss silly topics but um
authentically 100 Eric Griffin so make
sure you uh check that out if you want
so
um
check this out I'm saying so continue
but you know a lot of times people are
like I thought this was the comedy
podcast it's like you can go watch me be
funny on so many different things like
this weekend in Greensboro so happy New
Year chats good to see you guys glad you
guys are here
um I had uh such a um
you know I had a I had a just
interesting holidays holidays were were
weirdish and they went weird it was just
kind of low-key it was my first holiday
being married right so that was pretty
that was great you know Rachel's so
low-key though she loves to decorate so
she we had like a bunch of great
decorations in the house and Rachel's
also Jewish so we had like a wall of you
know Jewish stuff and then we had a
Christmas tree and then Rachel likes to
you know she she really got into the
Christmas spirit bought a bunch of gifts
to put under the tree for me and we had
stockings and you know I got her this
like really nice Cartier necklace that
she wanted it like matches a bracelet
that I got her from before so I knew she
wanted that one and so I got her that
which is like a big gift so I didn't
have a bunch of gifts for her but that's
a great gift so she got that so that was
beautiful uh she also got me this uh
ring she got me this
Aura ring is that how you call it oh are
you or anyway it's one of those rings
that tracks all your your sleeping and
like your movement and all that kind of
stuff and takes your heart rate and your
pulse you know it's kind of interesting
I wonder if I could pull up the um
oh man I wonder if I could wait you know
what let me see if I could uh
pull up the information for you guys and
all you guys listening right now I
appreciate you guys listening on Apple
podcast and Spotify and all the the all
the great things that you guys normally
listening to me on I appreciate you guys
for listening and so you know you might
if you ever hear me talking about a
picture or something like that you might
want to go check it out for yourself and
see it let's see if this works ah no it
doesn't I didn't
I have to uh I have to I have to change
the um
the the shot I don't know why I should I
should have done this ahead of time you
know what I mean like if I go change
Source yeah I can't even I can't even
change the source on this well anyways
I'll show you that next time but anyway
I got this ring you know so it's this
like you know and it has it has a lot of
interesting uh information
you know they have your like your sleep
pad I don't know how they can tell all
that from like just your pulse but it
tells you like your active calorie burn
you're like you know when you're in REM
sleep and all this kind of stuff so it's
pretty interesting I don't know I feel
like it's like a Tracker ring and then
Rachel's like follow me checking my
pulse and my heart rate make sure it's
not you know going up too high at a
particular time of night
I hear that's how I want I hear that's
how some guy got caught cheating there
was some story about that dad you know
she was looking at his health
information in like in the middle of the
night his heart rate was at a point
where like this seemed like some some
sex stuff
so
yeah I've been um I'm actually dad I
lost some weight I'm actually down six
pounds I've been taking some green stuff
I don't know like it's one of those
Instagram like caged I've been taking
like this daily green powder uh and also
some like uh uh what is it some just
other thing that's for like taking some
Fiber so like you know all my I feel
very regular I feel like I but I do feel
the difference I've also been taking
some lion's mane I'm up on that lines
man y'all know that my mom has dementia
so I've been taking lion's mane and I've
been like that I feel the difference I
feel like a little bit of energy and
memory recall that I was like you know
forgetting words or you know forgetting
act like I would be thinking about an
actor or actress and I'd be like what is
that person's name and it just would
like leave my brain and so now I've been
right recalling things a little better
so I think that's uh that's something
there so you know I got my hair cut
I went to a new place I shout out to my
lady that I normally go get but Rachel
was kind of like I'm tired of that
haircut so I went to this new place and
I'm also very bougie so I like
I like getting I like getting shampooed
I like getting my hair head massaged I
like I like the salon experience so I
was in Chicago and shout out to Zanies
last year I I sold out five shows in
Zanies man so I really appreciate all
the people that came out to see me in
Chicago and like I said we'll be in
Greensboro and I'll be in Norfolk
um uh what is it Norfolk uh where is it
what is the place uh not arcan not
Arkansas where is Norfolk
um Nebraska I'm gonna be in Nebraska
next week so anyways
I um what was I saying see look like I
need to take some more lines man because
I forgot exactly what the hell I was
talking about but anyways
um you know yeah I'm I do so many shows
and stuff like that that it's hard it's
hard and I know a lot of water too but
anyways I was in Chicago I remember now
and I was getting a haircut I needed a
haircut so I went to this like men's
place so it's like you know when you go
to a men's place it's like they they do
beards and all this kind of stuff and so
I've never been to a place like that in
a while that's like strictly Just For
Men and so the guy was like yeah I'll
take you right now because they they was
like appointment only but the guy took
me in in the middle of two appointments
and he had to do with fancy as hell he
was like Russian and he had like he was
like dressed like very like he was
dressed up you know what I mean and and
it was like all this wood stuff and you
know and it was it was nice looking so I
sat down and he had his scissors and he
was like
you know he was just doing it all fast
and he was like it was like I loved how
my hair was shaped and like he just knew
he had to beard all nice and I was like
oh this is it I got to go to a men's
place you know if you really want that
experience and you can still get the
salon experience at a men's place so so
I looked for one out here where on the
west side of La where I live and I found
a place and I went
you know and the lady was like you know
what she was like talky talky talky you
know what I mean like it was just one of
those like oh I've been she was in Show
Business and she was like you know she
was just going in talking about herself
and I was just like you know it was you
know I was like all right I can get used
to this and but she like you know she
was like I want to shape your hair a
certain way and do the back and I was
like I like when I go to a haircut place
I don't really act like a diva in terms
of how I want my hair to look some
people are like that you know what I
mean like some people are like hey you
know don't do this don't do that only
cut here sometimes when I go I feel like
the haircut person is an artist and I'm
like what do you see because I don't get
to see my hair like I'm looking at the
screen right now and I see myself but
for the most part you don't really look
at yourself everyone else is looking at
you so I think what's more important how
how you know how you're you know how
people see you and if other people like
oh I really like how that looks I mean
it's important that you think you look
good but I like the idea of like here's
a person that cuts hair for a living and
they they know what the follicles do and
how a hair is shaped so I was like yeah
go for it so you know I cut my hair a
little different I think it's going to
grow out and we'll see how it looks when
it comes out but I enjoyed that so I got
a good new haircut place so I'm gonna
check that out still go to my old lady
sometimes too but you know this is like
you sometimes you gotta go take
something different you know what I mean
gotta do something different so I did
that and then okay and so in terms of
like the new year you know I was like do
you have New Year's resolutions and I
just want to be more consistent with my
health that's my overall goal that has
nothing to do with 2023 this is just for
the rest of my life right so what's one
of my goals I don't know what your goals
are I'd love to see what your goals are
you can write them in the comments and
share with me what you guys if you guys
had some like you know new goals so I
that's what I want to do and another one
of my goals too is to like not be on my
phone as much not be checking on social
media not I realize you know the more
like say famous you get or the more you
have outside things in your life that
are affecting like how people look at
you or all that kind of stuff you just
get a lot of like there's like a lot of
negative and there's a lot of positive
uh you know but there's enough negative
that you just go ah man who wants to see
this right and I realized to myself I
was like why am I putting myself through
that I remember asking Rogan a long time
ago when I started doing the podcast and
I said hey man do you look at comments
like do you look at uh negative comments
or what do you do and he goes man I
don't look at negative comments I don't
look at positive comments because
they're just as damaging to your psyche
and I was like oh wow so I realized I
was like oh as much as I love being on
social media and you know making videos
and stuff like that I just I'm on a
thing now where I'm just like all right
I don't care say what you want do what
you want has nothing to do with me I
just I'm gonna worry about my happiness
I can't be worried about you know other
people's happiness or lack thereof
because you know trolls are going to be
trolls man so more power to you but I'm
it's not I'm not I'm on a new thing and
I and I have been now for a couple of
weeks and it's actually I feel the
difference it's been great you know so
yeah I'm all about that I'm all about
that new life so that's what I did and
so then for New Year's I don't know what
you guys did for New Year's but Rachel
and I went we stayed in Malibu we went
to this like beautiful hotel in Malibu
that I didn't even know it was a hotel
it was right on the beach it was
expensive we just stayed for one night
but I was like let's do a little
staycation you know and then we went to
dinner at Morton's we went to is it
Mortons yes Morton's on PCH so they had
a beautiful like you know all the
balloons and all that stuff were in
there so we had a really nice dinner and
then we went back to the hotel and we
just like you know we had like we
brought some like apple cider and you
know and we just like enjoyed each
other's company and that's one of the
things I love about my wife she's just
like you know it don't got to be fancy
it don't got to be like she's fancy
about certain things you know she's
fancy about like she wants a certain
person she likes pampering herself and
that kind of thing but when in terms of
like doing things like like we love just
spending time with each other and we
could just do it you know so it was like
this beautiful ocean view even though
the weather was a little funky on New
Year's night but then the next day it
was beautiful we had a great breakfast
at the place we went for a walk and it
was like oh this was the I couldn't have
you know celebrated the New Year's any
better than with this uh beautiful woman
so
shout out to Mrs Griffin and all that
she brings to my life
all right this is a good time to uh get
a commercial break in everybody so let's
uh let's talk about our dear friends at
what is this one we're doing right now
at doordash our
I just want to thank them for being a
sponsor here at doordash
you know
um I love doordash cause sometimes you
just you want food or sometimes you've
gone to the market and you've forgotten
something so they don't just order from
like your favorite restaurants around
you can get a bunch of things that you
need and that's the the you know that's
that's that's one of the things I think
is golden about doordash it's like the
restaurants you love like I say
groceries you can get essential items
and then every time you place an order
for pickup or delivery you're setting
off a chain reaction that helps give
back to the people who make your
neighborhood unique you know because
it's like we all have some tough times
and so I I really much uh love
supporting some of the small places that
are on the app you know with doordash
you're not just getting the things you
love but you're supporting the community
you love too and I think that is super
important you know
um yeah you know I highly recommend
doordash and they're not they're a great
sponsor of the show and I'm a person
that uses it so for a limited time our
listeners can get 50 off their first
order of 15 or more when you download
the doordash app and enter code Griffin
Griffin r-i-f-f-i-n enter code refin
that's 50 off your first order of 15 or
more when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter code refin
riffin don't forget that's code riffin
for 50 off your first order with
doordash subject to change terms apply
also one of our great sponsors of the
show this week is Draft Kings guys the
NFL picture is locked I'm gonna be
talking about that soon the NFL picture
was locked uh so you can place go go to
a place for Wild Card round action is
DraftKings sports book an official
sports betting partner of the NFL to
kick off the road to the Super Bowl 57
wow can he believe it's Super Bowl 57
new customers can bet just five dollars
and get 200 and free bets instantly guys
do you hear what I'm saying 200 and free
bets instantly I love the NFL that's the
only thing if I ever bet I bet on the
NFL I go to Vegas every year uh for the
Super Bowl because it's such a fun time
and then you know you have your
DraftKings app up on your phone and you
could just do all the bets and things
that you want to do
the NFL playoff picture is locked so get
out there get your 200 and free bets
instantly download the draftking sports
app and use code riffin Griffin new
customers can get five dollars on the
NFL and get 200 and free bets instantly
only at draftking Sportsbook with code
riffin minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see the show notes
for details thank you DraftKings
okay guys uh you know gotta secure the
bag uh make sure you know we're
supporting the show
all right so since I was just talking
about
um what do you call it uh uh the the NFL
let's talk about the NFL picture this
year you know let's talk about the NFL
playoffs man the NFL playoffs are here
and it is super exciting you know but
first I would be remiss if I didn't talk
about uh Damar Hamlin which happened
last week uh listen last week Football
was footballing last week you know
Football was footballing last week and I
think we were reminded that it's a
dangerous sport and these young men are
putting their themselves on the line and
there is a risk of injury kind of like
when kind of like race car drivers you
know
it doesn't happen all the time but there
is risk there could be a terrible
accident it's the same thing with these
super athletic strong powerful men are
slamming into each other every week on
occasion something like this can happen
and it was on such a public stage I
think again we were reminded of that
it's just a game and I actually really
appreciated how for the most part we
were kind of like as a as a nation just
kind of like if football fans were like
oh man I hope this dude's okay and I
know this is just a game and we were
kind of like supporting him and if
people were supporting his
um what do you call his toy drive and
just supporting him and a lot of people
were coming out and talking about it and
there were some people also some
football players who were out there
talking about like like Dominique
Foxworthy on um on ex football player
he's on ESPN you know he was just really
talking about players rights and how we
don't know about a lot of things they're
not letting us know that like you know
sometimes people that there's been
people who have died in the locker room
from football related injuries that
happen on the the field we don't hear
about that stuff we don't hear about the
the the effects of CTE and we don't we
don't enough we don't hear about how so
many players actually are affected and
and then you know if they're going to
put their their health and safety and
their livelihood on the line you know
they should be compensated you know
especially from the richest Sports
League
there there is other than you know
soccer soccer clubs but you know so I
understand that this is like bringing
that to the Forefront you know we often
hear them we we hear about these big
contracts but those are from like
quarterbacks who are not necessarily and
they're protected you know these other
guys these like fifth round picks and
these fourth round picks with the
average uh career of three years and
they need to make as much money as they
can because who knows what they're gonna
do after that or you know you know what
I'm saying so it's like we're from you
know we we put a lot of money into
football we got the the packages that we
get we buy in jerseys and we're buying
tickets and we're watching commercials
for cable and we're you know all the all
the things that we do to support uh
football because we love it we have to
remember that I don't all that money
doesn't always trickle down to the
athletes and then there are parents out
there I don't know if you're a parent
out there and you could talk to talk
about this in chat in the chat talk
about it in the comments I mean would
you let your kids play football like did
it change your mind after you saw what
happened to this guy or anytime you see
injuries like that you know are you are
you like I don't think I want my kid to
play football you know Rachel already
said to me like she was like I don't
wanna if we have kids I don't want them
to play football so it's like you know
what I mean it is a real feeling so I
know I don't know how many parents are
out there what do you guys uh think
about it and so let me know what your
thoughts are but anyways Demar hanlon's
out of the hospital he seems to be doing
okay I don't know what this means for
his career I don't know if it was just a
freak accident his body's gonna recover
and he'll be back on the field next year
who even knows I mean I think we're
super concerned about Optics and how
things look especially what was going on
in Miami with with uh two of the Tonga
two of iloa whatever the hell you say
his name you know he had all these
concussion things and so it's like he
got another concussion and so it's like
he was in concussion protocol then it's
kind of a thing where you go you go like
hey man worry about yourself in your
career I don't know if this year's
playoffs are the time to like Risk this
because if it happens again they're
gonna be we're gonna be looking side eye
at Miami like why are you playing this
guy he had he's had three concussions in
one year so how does that affect you
know
somebody's thought process for
you know if you're gonna let your kids
play football or not is the juice worth
the squeeze absolutely that's Frederick
in chat I totally agree with you is the
juice worth the squeeze and so we got to
make sure that these players are well
what are we gonna do we don't even care
we just want to make sure football's on
on Sunday football's actually the one
sport that I'm still as interested in
after the pandemic
I just I love basketball but it's so
frequent that I don't find myself
wanting to watch it as much as I did
before but football is like I love it
it's perfect sports like once a week
maybe twice a week you know but you
watch it I watch Red Zone I'm getting
all the games you're looking at your
fantasy team my fantasy team was an
absolute disaster this year by the way
so you look at your fantasy team and you
just you know you just you just go in
you just you just it's a perfect amount
of sports that you could go on with your
life so I don't know
but football talk this season has been I
think this has been one of the best NFL
seasons in a long time and this playoffs
is turning out to be one of this like
I'm really looking forward to see what's
going on in this year's playoffs so in
the in the NFC you got the the
Philadelphia Eagles who's had an
outstanding season all year they've had
the most complete team from top to
bottom Jalen Hurst who I believe should
win the MVP just because they have the
best record in the league they finish
with the number one seed and the two
games that he was out they lost those
games and they lost them to me because
of the lack of his presence him not
being there and what he does for that
team showed how valuable he really is to
the Eagles being the most valuable
player so I think Jalen Hershey went in
the MVP but if Patrick Mahomes win ends
it I got no problem with that too
because they do bald out but we'll get
to the AFC so you got the Eagles at the
number one seed and they're waiting for
the lowest seed person whoever the
lowest seed is so like if Tampa wins
they'll play Tampa if uh whoever has the
lowest or it could be uh Seattle
depending on if they beat the Niners so
Philly's looking good I think they have
a chance to win the Super Bowl Dallas
can they can they get the monkey off
their back can they break their lack of
playoff that's this playoff curse 25
years since they won a Super Bowl or
even won a significant playoff game so
we'll see what's going on with Dallas
they have a really great team too but
they did they look like crap against
Washington last week so it's like what
is what is going on with them going into
the playoffs but they got an outstanding
record I think they won 13 games
themselves so but Philly was just better
NFC East turned out the NFC East turned
out to be one of the best divisions in
football this year so that was great so
you got uh Dallas they're looking good
Tampa Bay how can you bet against Tom
Brady even though that team looked like
hot garbage all year and they're going
into the playoffs with a losing record
but you got Tom Brady right you got Tom
Brady so it's like can you bet against
him I think you have to go with Tom
Brady and tell Tom Brady loses until his
body goes dude we're 45. we can't do
this anymore okay so we'll see
now the most intriguing one right now in
the first round is the Giants versus the
Vikings the Vikings they have a great
record but sometimes they just look like
garbage they lost some games this year
to some really really good teams and you
thought oh man not only did they lose
they got their butts kicked so I think
that's primed for an upset I think the
Giants are gonna beat the Vikings you
know but maybe Kirk Kirk cuckens Kirk
Cousins can get the monkey off his back
and actually win another playoff game
show up in the clutch and show that he
is deserving all the money that he's
gotten and take this team with Jefferson
all the way you know as far as he can
NFC Championship or something but you
know they're looking good as a three
seed I like in Vikings but I think I
actually think that the Giants are gonna
beat them you know and then you got the
Seattle versus San Francisco who knows
you got Gino Smith who resurrected his
career on under uh what's his face over
at Seattle
um you know who knows Seattle's been up
and down but they made it into the
playoffs and
I just don't know
I don't know if they uh
if they I don't know you know what I
mean like it's like which Seattle is
going to show up and but then they're
going against the best defense in the
league another team I think has the
potential to win the Super Bowl and
that's the San Francisco 49ers I think
San Francisco is a a tremendous team and
I love this kid Brock Purdy the last
pick in the draft he's out here with
some swag the dude like he got swag he
acts like he's been in the league 10
years he got he's pointing and he's like
doing his thing and you know uh the that
coach what's his name um who's the coach
of uh this thing I think it's Shanahan
right Shanahan's kid yeah yeah yeah uh
he is like he's got he's he knows how to
get the best out of quarter quarterbacks
that don't normally look great but we'll
see man
um we'll see I think that I think that
it reminds me of the Patriots
when
um Drew not droopies Drew Bledsoe got
hurt and Tom Brady took over he never
lost a job he was a late round pick he
was a game manager with this really
tremendous defense and they went all the
way to the Super Bowl man this could be
the start of something great for this
young kid Brock Purdy so we'll see if he
can do this in the playoffs if the if
the if it's not too much for him so
shout out to uh the Niners so my picks
really are I think the Eagles can win I
think the teams that have a legit jits
shot to win in the in the NFC it's only
two teams for me it's the Eagles and the
49ers they're at the top of the list and
then after that it's a kind of like who
knows you know like if Dallas can
finally win a couple of games if Dallas
gets themselves in the NFC Championship
right then yeah obviously they have a
shot but you be looking at them
differently you'll be like they finally
put it together and then if Tom Brady
can make a magical run but other but
other than that that is the Eagles and
the Giants to me that are at the top of
the class
now in the AFC which is hands down the
better conference this year there are I
feel like
for these teams got a legit shot because
of talent to win the Super Bowl so
Kansas City obviously Patrick Mahomes
has proven he's one of the greatest and
working on being the greatest of all
time he just needs to rack off a few
more Super Bowls because that's all it
really takes if you you know look Tom
Brady has seven and that's tremendous
probably no one will ever have that
again but there's four of those where it
wasn't because of him he was a game
manager with less than 300 yards in all
the games and a kick one you know a kick
won the damn game you know what I mean
and the defense was tremendous so you
know but he was a part of that and so it
counts but when you look at Patrick
Holmes you know they're winning because
of him and his talent his throws he got
to get 375 yards and that kind of thing
so I think Patrick Mahomes he if he wins
the MVP I'm with it and their team is
great losing Tyree kill was great for
him because it made him you other people
and really showcase his quarterback
ability so
kudos to them they got a legit shot the
best shot right then you got buffalo
buffalo they were the Super Bowl
favorite to start the season you got uh
what's his name uh Josh Allen tremendous
Talent tremendous Talent right that team
looks great now they're playing with
that sort of like let's do it for Demar
Hamlin feel to them they got robbed
because the NFL took away that game so
they had no chance to actually win the
AFC number one seed so maybe they got a
chip on their shoulder maybe they got
something to play for maybe it's time
for Buffalo if Buffalo wins the Super
Bowl I would not be shocked they were
favored anyway so they have a super
legit chance all right they're playing
against Miami I don't think Miami has a
chance against Buffalo I don't know if
two was playing but they just they just
they tanked in the end of the season so
I can't go with uh the Miami Dolphins
then you got the Bengals I have no issue
or no problem with picking the Bengals
to win the Super Bowl people they are
bawling right now you hear me they
balling and they were beating buffalo in
that game okay they had an actual shot
to win but Casey won so they they would
have won regardless of the Bengals would
have won but I'm just saying Bengals
look good Joe Bro is the truth boy is
good cocky as hell too he was like my
window was always open as long as I'm
playing that's what he said something
like that
so they have a legit shot I don't think
the bravens have a chance against them
just because of this whatever is going
on with uh Lamar Jackson he hasn't
practiced in over 30 days I don't see
how someone like that with how he plays
could just step on the field and make a
difference if I was him I wouldn't play
I would be like nah I'm not playing
I need to get my money you know he need
to get his 250 million dollars next year
so if I was him I wouldn't play they
still got a good team they're there
because of him but I don't think they
have a chance okay I think that Bengals
put the whoop on them
and then you got this intriguing matchup
of Trevor Lawrence with uh the Jags and
then you got what's his name uh what's
what's the quarterback from the Chargers
name uh um
come on come on chat give me the
Chargers guy's name uh I'm forgetting
names again that's how I gotta take my
lion's mane but uh they look good too
man they really
like the Chargers
they remind me like they're like a
sneaky team that can like sneak in there
because they have Justin Herbert thank
you Justin Herbert like the AFC has the
best quarterbacks Justin Herbert uh
Lamar Jackson in the playoffs I would
take all these quarterbacks over the
other side man you know what I mean like
Justin Herbert is a that dude's a beast
man he got skills Trevor Lawrence has
got he's got his [__] together I like
him Patrick Mahomes Joe burrow Lamar
Jackson Josh Allen and even two uh if he
plays he was right up there in the MVP
consideration in the early part of the
year they got the best quarterback so
when you got these kind of quarterbacks
anything can happen right so look out
for the Chargers like the Chargers they
should win this game in my opinion the
charges should beat Jacksonville
Jacksonville Jacksonville is an
up-and-coming team and they're looking
good uh the the the the coach got them
playing you know the guy that we used to
coach for the Philly when they won the
championship so they got him playing
good but to me Justin Herbert needs to
put his stamp all all over this game and
they should win that game in my opinion
so but I think Bengals are going to win
Buffalo is going to win I think the
Chargers are going to win and then
whoever the lowest seed is there is
going to play KC and then get whooped by
them but who knows uh you know I'm
telling you right now the Bengals have
beaten KC three times in a row so to go
to the Super Bowl too so don't be
shocked if you see the Bengals in the
Super Bowl so we'll see what happens but
anyways that's it guys I know for all
you people that are bored with sports
you hated this whole segment but it is
what it is that's what Daddy does we
talk about all kinds of stuff
all right so let's get into one of the
things I really enjoyed and wanted to
talk about
this year if you can see the thumbnail
of
uh uh the thumbnail of the episode
Eric Tarr
Avatar to the way of the water
um no spoilers really I mean at this
point I think you can already see what
the the movie's about I don't know if
you guys saw the first avatar
you know I remember the first Avatar and
the thing that I was like amazed about
was the special effects like this this
real true 3D because remember like they
brought this 3D back and then like you
know you would pay an extra to watch 3D
but the movie really wasn't in 3D They
just added like a bird in the beginning
of the movie flying out at you and
you'll be like oh that's it that's all
the 3D you're not gonna have no real 3D
but this movie the the field of view the
depth of the movie and the first avatar
was amazing and so we saw this like I
think we were like enamored by the
technology it reminded me of Jurassic
Park when I first saw Jurassic Park just
seeing those dinosaurs for the first
time on the screen looks so real I think
that's what we really were enamored by
Avatar but like once you saw the movie a
couple times then you were just kind of
like okay whatever I'm done with Avatar
and then it just went away like I wasn't
like how come they didn't make Avatar 2
like I didn't really care I don't think
anybody cared but it was the highest
grossing movie of all time worldwide box
office it was number it was still number
one it wasn't like other movies did
better like you know uh when Avengers
and all that stuff came out but I even
believe that worldwide box office I
think Avatar was uh number one you know
what am I doing Griffin's right here
Griffin what are you doing Griffin just
look at it you know Box Office Mojo box
office shout out to Box Office Mojo love
that website I always go to that so you
go to uh worldwide box office
uh all time
here we go
all time uh worldwide yeah Avatar still
number one top lifetime gross is almost
3 billion dollars worldwide
then it's then it goes tour story four
then it goes Lion King uh you know it's
crazy you know what I mean so top
lifetime grosses let's look at this list
yeah oh no my bad here we go here's the
list right now oh you know what let me
let me just go to share screen there you
go let's look at it there you go guys
look at me look at me
let's let's wait let me zoom in on this
a little bit there we go put it here all
right so if you look at the list for the
people listening I'll read it for you
but it's like Avatar is number one for
Life worldwide gross you know
2.9 billion I mean yeah almost three
billion dollars and then it's Avengers
end game which I totally get Titanic
another James Cameron movie by the way
and then it goes Star Wars Avengers
Infinity War Spider-Man no way home and
then the Avatar way of the water he's
already got the seventh he's got three
movies in the top seven of all time
gross isn't that crazy so the dude's
doing something right so again I wasn't
really like
I wasn't excited about it right I'm
gonna tell you right now I wasn't
excited about Avatar and again it's not
really a spoiler so if you saw the first
one you know I'll just read from uh uh
IMDb Jake Sully lives with his Newfound
family formed on the extra extra solar
Moon Pandora once a familiar threat
returns to finish what was previously
started Jake must work with uh nadiri
and the army of Navi raised to protect
their home that's basically what the
movie's about you know once again the
white man is coming to take the land
away from the Indians you know what I
mean that's just that's basically what
it is you know
you know what I mean it's like you know
there's just another movie where white
people are terrible sorry I I don't
necessarily agree with it but it is what
it is you know what I mean so so that's
basically what the movie's about okay so
this is what I want to say about Avatar
um
it was beautiful like
the dude did a good job for to take 10
years and spend a bunch of money get a
bunch of great writers probably like
collaborate with people on a scale that
is like I think he understands how to
collaborate I thought it was a
tremendous movie you know we live in
woke sensitive times right now where
people like to nitpick and and take
apart a movie and everybody's so
negative about everything just
forgetting all that nonsense guys about
cultural appropriation about race and
all this nonsense that people are always
looking at
just do trust me put all that outside of
your head and just go enjoy this movie
you know what I mean I'm telling you
it's you get lost in it like I thought I
was watching National Geographic like I
thought I was watching like oh they're
doing a like a documentary on on this
space world that they found that's how
beautiful it looked that's how real it
looked it was really it was really
spectacular and fantastic and just go
with an open mind of like looking for
escapism this was the movie for that it
is total escapism and like I say it was
beautiful it was a beautiful story I I
was with the story you know I was like
oh this is nice this family struggle
that's like trying to raise your kids in
a in a world where you're trying to like
be a father but you're trying to protect
them but at the same time you're trying
to make sure they're strong and then I
remember being a kid and rebelling
against my parents and like I want to
prove myself huh you know there was loss
there was uh uh Triumph there was you
know it was really it was really
beautiful you know
and I shout out you know what I mean I I
think you should for sure watch it I
give this movie 10
woo-woos I would I would recommend it I
I would go watch it again but it is long
long y'all wow three hours it's a three
hour long movie a little wait wait more
than three hours and when you go to the
movie theaters now
these movie theaters are showing almost
30 minutes of previews and
um all that other fluff that like the
movie theater stuff like all the AMC
stuff that they're showing plus 25
minutes of movie trailers plus three and
a half hours of movie so this was a four
hour experience but I tell you
I tell you this right now you'll enjoy
it if you didn't enjoy it I get that too
man it's not for everybody but I'm a I
love fantasy man I'm a fantasy guy I
read fantasy books when I do my book
club you know I'm always talking about
this guy and shout out to Christopher G
Nuttall he's my favorite author right
now look him up Christopher G nuddle and
check out the book series called
schooled in Magic and he has spin-off uh
series from this world he created it's I
love that stuff so I like getting lost
and stuff and I was sitting there with
my buddy Owen Smith very funny comic
shout out to Owen Smith
um we were just he we went after The
Comedy Store it was late man we went at
like 10 o'clock
you know you know what's funny so I
asked Rachel ahead of time I was like do
you want to see Avatar it's three hours
and she was like hell no I don't want to
see that Rachel just can't sit in a
movie she cannot sit in a movie for
three hours I just it's not gonna happen
so I said to her would you mind if I go
with my friends and watch the movie she
was like yeah I'm not gonna watch it
okay so then it's like I'm at The Comedy
Store in Hollywood and it's like 10 30.
it's late so my boy Owen says yo man
let's go see Avatar I talked to my wife
and you know so he you know he's married
with two kids and he got it he got out
of that and he's like yo let's go see a
10 45 p.m showing of the movie so Rachel
has to work really early so I text her I
go babe I know you're sleeping but I'm
gonna go check out this movie Avatar
this is probably a good time to see it
your sleep all right when I get home
it's like she's getting up to go to work
okay because she gets up early because
she has to get ready so she gets up like
an hour and a half before she needs to
leave so she's she's up you know it's
like 2 30 in the morning and she's
getting up I'm walking in I said I'll
make coffee for you so I make coffee now
she starts going in she's like oh you
went to the movie without me like you
what you didn't even want to you didn't
even want to go see this movie and she's
all like yes I did I'm gonna go see it
they always do this she always does this
man she always acts like oh I was gonna
go see Avatar me and my girlfriends are
gonna go see it oh really you and your
girlfriends are gonna go see Avatar okay
okay Rachel you I I can't wait for that
you know she hasn't gone to seen it yet
so I was like I know you didn't want to
see this movie you just imagined I was
out having fun without you and then she
comes up with some stuff yeah I just I
like sleeping next to you I like knowing
you're you know you're there with me
asleep and then when I wake up you're
asleep and I see you
you know you know you know what guys I
just got to tell you
I don't get mad about this stuff I'm
gonna give you some grown ass advice for
you young couples you young dudes in
these relationships when your woman goes
starts talking about that don't take it
personal don't don't sit there and be
like you you know I don't have a fight
with her now I get it you have to know
she's just a little jealous you know
what I mean they jealous of your time
they they don't want you being with
anyone else you know they don't want you
like she don't even like when I do
comedy because she's like oh you're
sharing yourself with other people I get
it it don't it don't even it don't even
bother me so I just like like all right
baby I know you just you know you just
whatever and then she'll they'll laugh
they'll actually
if you don't make it a big deal they'll
let you know that it's really not a big
deal I'm just feeling this right now and
I want to say it just let your woman say
that let your woman just Express this
like illogical emotional response to
something because she'll she'll correct
herself you know they're emotion
emotional creatures and you got to allow
that you have to allow it you know what
I'm saying and once you get married you
you just know you're gonna drive
yourself crazy if you're trying to have
everything be logical or everything be
like how our brains work it don't work
like that and you'll you'll drive
yourself crazy being like that so it was
just a fun thing between us and then you
know then you know she hasn't talked
about it since because I know she ain't
ever gonna go watch Avatar even if it's
on cable and we watch it on the TV she
ain't gonna watch it oh by the way I got
myself let me just real quick but
anyways I I highly recommend Avatar 10
woo-woos
[Music]
so go see Avatar
um but I want to say this too I I I've
always wanted to splurge on myself for
something when I splurge on myself it's
always something Electronics so I got
myself a 8K Samsung quad whatever you
call it television
and it's 85 inches oh my God but there's
no AK content
right
and it's like
I have YouTube TV and shout out to
YouTube TV I love YouTube TV but some of
the channels aren't even in 4k which is
really annoying like some of the
channels when you get YouTube TV they're
only 720p so like I I hated how funky it
looks on the TV all blown up but there
are other things that are 4K like you
know there's some streamy stuff but
anyways my point is
you have to go to there's no AK content
yet anywhere except for YouTube If you
have an 8K TV and you go to YouTube Type
in search for 8K
and you put the YouTube app on your TV
oh it's like
you're just like damn this is the future
like it's crazy how it looks
so anyway just a small Flex that I got
an AK TV all right let me finish with my
last
um
my last review of this episode is the
show and or
um
let me tell you something
no spoilers I don't know if I'm gonna
spoil I'm not gonna spoil and door
do I spoil Ander okay so this is a
prequel series I didn't even know this
you know what I was gonna I'm looking at
the IMDb right now and I wasn't sure you
know all these Star Wars shows one of
the things they really like got me was
like what's the timeline like like
Mandalorian for instance like I was like
when the hell is Mandalorian you know I
was like in Mandalorian like it it
collided with uh Boba Fett right but I
was like when is this and then we
figured it out because it was like after
Return of the Jedi so Return of the Jedi
is done and then because they had Luke
Skywalker in it so he was like okay now
I know where this is I didn't know where
the hell Andor was but now I know on the
IMDb because it says prequel series to
Star Wars Rogue one is an error filled
with danger deception and Intrigue
Cassian will embark on the path is uh
path is just destined to turn him into a
rebel hero that's basically what the
show is about so this it's like what I
love about the Star Wars universe is
that we know the Universe I love a good
Universe okay that's why I love fantasy
books you look fantasy books and then
they create this like just fantastic
universe and so why leave it like why
put it behind us so Star Wars is 40
Years of
you know we know so much about it you
know 40 40 Years of you know
what is that word
um
you know when you have all the backstory
stuff you know
I'm getting old guys because I'm
forgetting things but anyways you know
we have like so much story we know we
know where it came from we know you know
what I mean we know all of the
we know all of the um
the characters and we kind of got an
idea of like this is the Empire and this
is whoever so the fact that like uh the
the people that own it now can be like
well let's just make let's just make
some characters that's going on in this
world and then we'll show you what's
happening while other things that you
know about are going on so this is one
of those shows so I gotta tell you
though
first three yeah lore lore is not the
word I'm looking for I want somebody to
get this word that's in my head that I
can't think uh it's like um it's like
you know it's like having like an index
of like things that have happened and
then you know uh and then people follow
that even if a new writer comes in they
take that stuff and then they write I
forgot the word man whatever
um but anyways
foreign
it's a really
it's a really great show but I'll say
this
the it's not backstory guys I see you
guys in the chat trying to help me but
it's on these lines it's the same as
like lore it's the same as like
backstory Canon thank you
d-o-oomf doom do MFA he got it Canon is
the word thank you I won't forget that
okay that's gonna be one of the things I
gotta keep in my head to remember that I
forgot that word but yeah so like it's
like you know they are following the
Canon I guess whatever you call it uh
Nick Cannon so they got a bunch of kids
no
um so the first three episodes of Andor
is slow as hell I'm telling you I had
trouble I actually stopped watching it
I actually stopped watching
um
because I was like I can't I can't stay
with this this is too boring for me
right but then I heard people talking
about it they were like dude Andrew is
so good so I was like let me give this
another look and so I I finished the
episode that I was on and then I started
watching and telling you
episode 4 on that show really picks up
the dude that stars in the show what's
his name Diego Luna he puts on a great
performance man everybody like you're so
invested in this little Universe within
the universe that we know you're so
invested in it and like his story and
just like you know you get you all the
characters are doing a great job you
know you kind of and you and you feel
like and oh let me tell you my favorite
part about this show I don't want to
give any more spoiler I'm not going to
spoil it but this is one of the this is
the main reason why I love this show
this is the first time that
I got a sense that the Empire the bad
guys that they weren't idiots
like this is the first time I got a
sense of like
here here are people within this bad
organization
and they believe themselves to be right
and they're capable and smart and you
know you're like the the lady the the
villain she's not even a villain she's
kind of the villain she's because she's
like you know she works for this sort of
like secret police you know and she's
smart and conniving and cunning and and
you just go man how are they gonna beat
these people and and then on the other
side you know preparing this preparing
this Rebel force and this Rebel Alliance
they have to make horrible choices to
inspire people and it's just like it's a
great story
and or to me Mandalorian to me is the
best I love Mandalorian the best
um but this is right there man I'm
telling you this is right there with
Mandalorian then Boba Fett because but
Boba Fett didn't get good until it
turned into Mandalorian
you know what I mean so I highly
recommend Andor if you haven't watched
it stick through those first three
episodes y'all you hear what I'm saying
stick through those first three episodes
get through them and you will enjoy that
show you heard it from here
um guys this season of riffin with
Griffin or this iteration of Griffin
we're gonna we're gonna continue to um
you know do reviews talk about stuff I
want to have um I'm doing real world
advice from a grown ass man you know I
think on my patreon episode I might go
into more detail on some shows that I've
been watching and like uh you know or
even like you know go with the chat uh
you know how I do that is I I like to
take my patreon episodes on Twitch which
is at Eric Griffin gaming but it's a
private I make it uh subscribers only uh
so you can only watch for like five
minutes and you gotta be a subscriber to
watch look if you want to support me you
can support me in many different ways
you could be a twitch subscriber which
you'll see me on most days doing that uh
you can join the patreon which I got
more episodes for that coming uh you
could be you could be a YouTube member
too if you want to be a YouTube member
you could do that too all right so you
know support riffing with Griffin in any
in the ways that you want to support it
uh you know financially or just by just
watching and sharing that that is you
know I I need that too so I I really
appreciate
I really appreciate all of that
um stuff okay so as you know we'll
finish off the episode with another one
of my my Chris Chris Woo my dude makes
all these dope beats so you guys know
what this is and again thank you for
watching thank you for listening to
riffin with Griffin and here we go with
the rap recap
oh yeah
it's the rap recap
I'm glad we back
step up against slap
it's a precision
Avatar
[Music]
huh
Star Wars War
the show was hardcore
remember the Lord
[Music]
continue to watch
continue to listen
[Music]
look at my face
old school raps
glad we back
every G spit it's fast
just like that
I'm not gonna be on my phone
you'll see
thanks for watching y'all and we'll be
here next week once again live unless I
have a guest
but if not I'ma do my best
oh say it with your chest
better than the rest
oh oh the chat just passed my test
thank you everybody for watching river
Griffin and I'll see you next week
[Music]
foreign